where have you been I went to fill my
truck up
but you're not going to believe what it
cost me
and all right
gotta love the humor gotta love the puns
whoa that was some Spider-Man thing how
did he know that was happening and why
did that happen and how do you have the
strength to pull her off like that bear
do you know bear just came in to say hi
look at this face and he farted thanks
man squeezing in flame tonsils to Olivia
what
yeah
when things are swollen they're swollen
because your body's inflammatory cells
are creating an inflammatory Cascade a
process that is actively fighting off an
infection the body's creating the
swelling in order to create the optimal
environment to fight offset infection
but the issue is not the swelling it's
the infection right
okay oh
great catch pulling a baby's arm like
that can create a condition known as
nursemaid's elbow where you actually
created this location you could see that
the baby stops using the arm and that's
one of the telltale signs
oh
oh did he just kick him in the balls
oh with the exception of the ball kick
should I say testicle kick I don't even
know what the medical terminology here
testicular trauma the stuff on the arms
uh on the lats or the ribs and The Traps
that's not gonna leave any lasting
damage in most situations because you're
really causing superficial ecchymosis
which is like superficial bruising and
that will toughen you up because you
have to be able to distract yourself
from the pain but I don't see a lot of
harm coming from that
are you allowed to say anything very
weird stories any weird thing that's
happened to you I'm gonna assume or
guess that the OB GYN is going to say
something that was inserted into the
human body
was it the Gwyneth Paltrow vagina candle
to make it smell like a vagina I never
thought I would say these words in my
life and somehow this person Gwyneth
Paltrow is making me say these words and
somehow that's making me feel worse even
though I'm fact checking them when
you're allergic to peanut butter and
your EpiPen expires tomorrow
no don't do that and look if you have
like a recently expired Tylenol or Advil
and you're taking that they don't become
like toxic after the expiration date
they just become less effective so if
you're Tylenol for your headache isn't
as effective it's not the end of the
world but if your EpiPen is not
effective that's a huge life or death
issue that you need solved that's why
when the EpiPen expires you get a new
one right away same goes for insulin I
wake up in the morning I have 32 ounces
of room temperature water one lemon
squeezed in that like flushes everything
out water flushes everything out the
lemon could be a tasty addition maybe
you get a little bit of nutrients but
flushing everything out is really the
kidneys job I have 32 ounces of cold
pressed celery juice is really
alkalizing for your system well it's
great that you're alkalizing given the
fact that you just had lemon juice which
was acidifying your body couldn't do
that on its own it absolutely does it on
its own in fact it does it so well that
if your body drops out of this very
specific pH of 7.35 to 7.45 you go into
debt and also remember in your stomach
you have a pH of two very acidic so no
matter how much celery juice you're
drinking still gonna be more acid than
that bad boy I have this medical medium
smoothie heavy metal detox smoothie next
time you hear someone say they're
drinking a detox smoothie just replace
the word detox with Miracle potion
because that's what detox means that's
the new definition Webster we're
changing the definition when you look up
the word detox it has to say Miracle
potion what happens to you if you eat
nuts I have like yeah I go into an
anaphylactic shock so you guys have you
ever accidentally been served nuts that
just happened on this movie I did how is
that happening on a movie set where
they're aware of people's allergies they
were bringing around little chocolate
things and I'm like oh yeah I'll have a
little one and I ate it and it was full
of peanut butter and what happened I
went to anaphylactic I was rushed to the
emergency room so an anaphylactic shock
what happens is your throat actually
starts closing and if it closes
completely you die you also have a drop
in blood pressure that's why it's called
Shock and this blood pressure drop can
be fatal on its own that is why we a
Benadryl which is an antihistamine does
not really treat anaphylactic shock
because you're not just treating the
allergic component the histamine
component you're also treating the low
blood pressure component that is why you
use epinephrine Auto injectors into the
lateral medial thighs I started doing TM
yeah because I was listening to your
show and I started doing TM and I go I
can control
okay they're laughing but to some degree
a healthy mental state can mitigate the
effects of pain swelling perception
stress so in some ways he's right but
when it's that big of an anaphylactic
shock note in a situation like that you
almost want to be nervous and have an
adrenaline rush because essentially
you're giving yourself the benefit of
the medication so if you actually keep
yourself common don't release adrenaline
in a situation like anaphylactic shock
that's working backwards all right
oh it's an Audi so this is an umbilical
hernia essentially you have a weakness
in the abdominal wall in this area and
actually there's a condition where
post-pregnancy women will have a
separation of their abdominal wall
musculature this is a diagram an
explanation how to know if you have a
leaky gut there's no such thing one
chronic fatigue I have chronic fatigue
frequent headaches and brain fog I have
frequent headaches and brain fog armor
Colossians oh come on man strengthens
your gut barrier replenishes your
microbiome combats blood in constipation
and IBS I thought they're not allowed to
make claims FDA there's just so much
misinformation It prepares your entire
gut wall entire it just it's like they
send in little minions and they go on
the wall bear come here calm me down I
need emotional support this is what he's
trained to do see him having a panic
attack and he's helping me thank you
okay for all ages and Lifestyles all
ages all conditions all Lifestyles it
works for everything side effects none
remember if something doesn't have side
effects that means it doesn't have
effects period I just add four drops of
oil of oregano into water in the morning
and a lot of people in the health and
wellness profession literally refer to
it as a natural antibiotic
you know what happens when natural
products have proof behind them they
just become medicine aspirin came from
nature now we produce it it's a real
medication whatever is in her little
cute mason jar ain't a natural
antibiotic it really helps kill
germs these people are hilarious like
these these pseudo Health experts what
here's what is the most funny thing is
they say take this natural antibiotic
that kills all bacteria it's so good but
also take this probiotic which is
bacteria because it's so good
you can't have both when we give
antibiotics it's for a reason it's
because we see a bacteria that's causing
an infection we test for it we swab for
it we culture it and we see that it's
infecting you causing symptoms then we
treat it because then the risks are
outweighed by the benefits I wondered
what this beautiful plant was that was
just everywhere on the land that I
bought is it poisonous turns out it was
a poison oh no and it affected my body
tremendously well it's usually a lot of
these um poison oaks poison ivies
they're a Type 4 delayed
hypersensitivity reaction the type of
immune reaction that takes some time to
develop in situations like this when it
starts impacting the face many doctors
will start increasing the potency of
treatment to an oral steroid medication
like prednisone I went to the emergency
room because my eye was completely
closed shut at that point they had no
idea what to do with me well I know
exactly what to do I would give you an
oral steroid there was no reason for me
to be at the hospital you know what you
do if someone has poison oak in their
eye you probably give them an antibiotic
biotic and I drop who knows send them
home well no I mean you don't even need
an antibiotic in many of the instances
unless you've scratched it and created
an infection what you do need is
something to calm the immune response
which is what is responsible for the
swelling like prednisone or methyl
prednisone but they didn't do that
because they want to ruin my life well
no
um any time that the the visual system
starts getting impacted by these things
you don't know how it's going to play
out so keeping you for observation for a
day or two is not unreasonable I defend
the system there even though the system
itself sucks what can you eat to help
you make you feel better bananas okay
monkeys never collapse I don't know if
monkeys Never Cry monkey never crap
is that true because there are monkey
everyday bananas bananas have potassium
which is an important electrolyte but
actually if you're sweating a lot the
main electrolyte you're losing in that
sweat is sodium it's actually why
there's a big critique surrounding Prime
is that it doesn't have as much sodium
which makes it taste better so if you're
like a gamer just sitting at home it
tastes better but if you're a true
athlete you need some sodium replacement
patient stated all these nuts patient
educated other reports of taking Tylenol
to decrease the fever patients say the
only thing that's hot is your breath
yeah some of the documentation is funny
I've actually seen some really funny
things about patients doing some weird
things in bed when uh either the nurses
or the residents come to check on them
in the middle of the night or early in
the morning and by the way treating a
fever if it's incredibly incredibly high
and dangerous maybe if they're weak
cardiovascular standpoint and they're
really on the the brink of death they're
in the ICU maybe but the average healthy
person who has a mild fever fighting off
an infection lowering the fever
prolonged symptoms in many of the cases
this is not English this is in English
77 year old male complaining of
shortness of breath after having PCI a
percutaneous intervention usually scent
placement heart failure with reduced
ejection fraction type 2 diabetes
hypertension and coronary artery disease
77 year old male came over son of a
salt and pepper penis clean-ish
performed macaroni his heart froze
really excited for this to determine my
heart ticklers necessity could have
already died when you are in your fifth
energy drinking the radio starts
you got to be careful with these energy
drinks some of them have like 200
milligrams of caffeine the recommended
maximum amount is 400 and I know some
Starbucks products that have more than
that just in one product
oh
my God we need this child on my channel
okay not good chest compressions he's
fired the first thing he did was point
at someone and say you call for help
because if you just yell call for help
no one ends up calling for help you also
assigned a role and said you get the AED
because you take someone get the ad no
one gets the ad that's a different
blader you want to put that on the chest
and then check for pulse found there
were pulseless unconscious starting
chest compressions these aren't two
inches deep they're not 100 beats per
minute but I gotta give this guy props
the big Pharma companies who basically
sell billions hundreds of billions of
dollars worth of medication to people
okay if the medication I like where this
is actually worked then they wouldn't
have any more clients that's not true
because more people are born and will
have conditions and will need cures what
I will say negative about Pharma and I
can't verify this this is almost a
personal belief of mine I think Pharma
spends a lot of money targeting
individuals that have lifelong illnesses
that they can give a medication to that
will control their are symptoms but not
cure it they will not spend money
seeking a cure because if you could
Target an illness that a patient will
need to take medication for the rest of
their life that is the biggest return on
investment this type of corruption
happens with 100 billion dollar
organizations because like I said it's
hundreds of billions of dollars
greediness never stops man you know
these people always want more and more
and more this is a human trait that he's
talking about on the surface he's not
wrong just in the details there's some
inaccuracies have you ever seen a pair
of headphones oh yes that also doubles
as a personal hygiene device and they
specifically say not a medical device a
high efficiency filtration system that
allows you to tackle pollution on the go
these definitely feel like a product of
the future they're a product of the
future that should stay in the future
and not make its way into the present
based on my humble opinion as I shared
on the MKBHD Channel I'll give you a
rundown of what's wrong with this
product number one the particles that it
is filtering it's not to the HEPA
filtration standard because the HEPA
filtration standard is 0.3 microns have
to be filtered
99.95 and the way this thing works is it
actually blows air directly into your
nose and mouth so it doesn't have even a
full seal when we wear like an n95 mask
to the hospital we actually get fit
testing to make sure that there's a
perfect seal they put like a giant Hood
around us spray scents see if we can
smell them or not but then also this air
constantly blowing on your mucous
membranes your lips and your nose will
ultimately dry them out and remember we
have cilia in our respiratory tracts
which are those hair like projections
that beat at like a thousand beats per
minute and they filter those particles
to the size of like 0.5 microns and they
get stuck in the mucus we coughed them
out we sneeze them out we swallow them
and then if some dust or germ gets into
your lungs we have something known as
alveolar macrophages which is type of
white blood cell that actually consumes
that dust particle and then gets
eliminated through the body so there's a
lot that your body does ready to filter
these things at the end of the day
here's the thing I went on the CDC
website and chat fact top 10 causes of
death okay chronic respiratory illnesses
up there in the top 10 causes of death
in urban in urban environments you know
what's higher than that unintentional
injury you know what raises risks of
accidents wearing noise canceling
headphones in urban environments like
who is this product for if you truly
have allergies you truly want to protect
yourself from viruses throw on a
properly fit at 95 mask and I know
everyone's gonna point and say okay a
covid virus particle is 0.1 microns and
the n95 mask is called that 95 because
it stops 95 percent of 0.3 Micron sized
particles that means 0.1 should be able
to get through the reality is anything
smaller than 0.3 or larger than 0.3
actually gets stopped by the n95 mask
more efficiently the larger ones make
sense why but the smaller ones get
trapped more readily because of
something known as Brownian motion this
is when really small particles have such
a random motion within our gaseous
environment here on Earth that they end
up getting trapped more readily in the
filter of this mask and I actually love
product I have filters in my house
because you know why they're on because
I spend eight hours in my bedroom every
night several hours in my living room so
I want those areas filtered I want dust
out I want allergens out because it's a
good place to do it and it actually
works but in front of your face for one
hour with limited protection and a
thousand dollar price tag and one and a
half pounds on your head that's just a
pain in the neck